Bonjour à tous, aujourd'hui dans ScienceClic,
comment représenter visuellement la relativité
générale.
Cette vidéo a pour but de lister les différentes
représentations de la théorie, et d'en proposer
une nouvelle, que je n'ai pour l'instant rencontrée
nulle part alors qu'elle possède un grand
nombre de qualités.
L'idée derrière cette représentation est
d'exploiter au maximum le format vidéo, et
en particulier sa dimension temporelle, afin
de restituer fidèlement ce que nous disent
les mathématiques de la théorie.
Au collège puis au lycée on apprend que
la chute des corps peut-être modélisée
par une force, c'est la force de gravité,
le poids.
Cette force permet de décrire le mouvement
des objets, en disant qu’ils sont attirés
les uns par les autres, et en particulier
par les astres massifs comme la Terre.
Mais cette description n’est qu’une approximation
et ne fonctionne pas dans certains cas de
forte gravité, comme la trajectoire de Mercure
autour du Soleil.
C’est en 1915 qu’Albert Einstein va proposer
une nouvelle théorie, un modèle mathématique
rigoureux qui permet de décrire cette fois-ci
de façon plus exacte la chute des corps.
Pour Einstein il n'est plus question d'une
force qui agirait à distance, c'est le tissu
de l'univers lui-même, l'espace-temps, qui
va se déformer et entraîner les objets dans
leur chute.
Pour pouvoir expliquer cette théorie complexe
au grand public il est nécessaire de concevoir
des visualisations qui la rendent plus abordable.
La représentation qu'on en fait le plus souvent
est celle d'une grande toile élastique sur
laquelle seraient posés les astres massifs.
En déformant la toile sous leur poids, les
astres entraînent le mouvement des autres
corps dans leur direction, un peu comme une
bille dans un bol.
A priori cette visualisation présente deux
avantages conséquents.
Elle est très simple et intuitive, et elle
permet de bien comprendre que les corps s'attirent
de façon indirecte, par le biais d’un intermédiaire
sous-jacent, l’espace-temps, dont ils influencent
la géométrie.
Cela dit, bien qu'elle soit extrêmement répandue,
cette façon d’imager la relativité générale
présente un grand nombre de problèmes qui
la rendent peu rigoureuse.
Dans cette vidéo, nous allons tenter d'améliorer
cette image en lui apportant quatre modifications
majeures.
Pour commencer, l'image de la toile élastique
semble indiquer que les astres sont posés
sur l'espace-temps, comme des billes, alors
que dans la réalité l'espace-temps est le
tissu de l'univers qui les englobe, les contient.
Une première amélioration que l'on peut
apporter serait donc de représenter les objets
à plat sur la surface, de sorte que l’on
comprenne bien qu'ils ne sont pas extérieurs,
mais contenus à l'intérieur de l'espace-temps.
Ensuite, l'un des plus gros problèmes de
cette représentation est qu'elle explique
en quelque sorte la gravité par la gravité.
A la question "pourquoi la pomme tombe sur
Terre", cette visualisation semble répondre
que c'est parce que la pomme est attirée
vers le bas, ce qui la force à tomber le
long du creux dans la toile.
Pour expliquer la gravité dans l’espace-temps,
il n'est pas acceptable de faire appel à
une gravité à l’extérieur de l’espace-temps.
Il va donc falloir trouver un meilleur argument.
En l'occurrence, il est plus rigoureux de
dire que si les objets suivent le renfoncement
créé par la Terre, c’est parce qu’ils
se déplacent en ligne droite mais dans une
géométrie courbée.
Quand ils tombent les objets avancent tout
droit, mais la courbure de l’espace-temps
nous donne l’impression que ces trajectoires
sont déviées.
Pour comprendre on peut par exemple imaginer
la surface d’une sphère, sur laquelle deux
fourmis partiraient en direction du Nord.
Au départ les deux trajectoires sont parallèles,
et on pourrait penser qu’en avançant tout
droit, les deux lignes parallèles ne se croiseront
jamais.
Pourtant les deux fourmis finissent par se
rencontrer au pôle Nord.
Ceci est possible grâce à la géométrie
courbée de la sphère sur laquelle deux lignes
droites parallèles ont tendance à se rapprocher.
Dans l’espace-temps, le phénomène est
similaire, et les objets semblent s’attirer
alors qu’ils suivent simplement la courbure
en ligne droite.
Troisièmement, cette image d’un renfoncement
dans la toile est trompeuse.
En effet on pourrait être amenés à penser
que si l'espace-temps peut se courber c’est
grâce à l’existence d’une dimension
supérieure.
Ici par exemple la toile à deux dimensions
semble se courber dans une troisième dimension.
En réalité ce n'est pas le cas, et les mathématiques
de la relativité ne nécessitent aucune dimension
supérieure pour que l'univers puisse se courber.
Il est donc préférable de ne pas représenter
la toile vue de côté mais plutôt du dessus,
avec une grille qui donne l’idée de la
déformation.
Au passage ceci nous permet également de
rétablir les trois dimensions d'espace dans
lesquelles nous vivons.
Enfin, le problème le plus important de cette
représentation est le fait que notre diagramme
fait complètement abstraction de la dimension
temporelle.
L'espace-temps est un objet à 4 dimensions,
3 dimensions d'espace que l'on a déjà représentées,
mais également 1 dimension de temps, qui
peut elle aussi se courber et se déformer.
Représenter fidèlement une géométrie d’espace-temps
à quatre dimensions est strictement impossible
et il va donc falloir trouver une astuce.
Une première idée serait d'ajouter des petites
horloges à notre diagramme en chaque point
de la grille d'espace.
De cette façon la grille d'espace devient
une grille d'espace-temps, et on comprend
que le temps peut s'écouler de façons différentes
en fonction de l'endroit où l'on se situe.
Cela dit, ajouter des horloges à notre diagramme
ne nous donne pas beaucoup plus d’intuition,
et en particulier on ne comprend toujours
pas vraiment ce qui pousse les objets à tomber.
Si on lâche une pomme par exemple, pourquoi
la pomme se met-elle en mouvement vers la
terre ?
Pour comprendre, il est nécessaire de supprimer
une dimension d'espace pour pouvoir représenter
la dimension temporelle.
En effet, c’est bien la composante temporelle
de la courbure qui permet d’expliquer la
gravité.
Dans un tel diagramme, on comprend que la
pomme est en fait constamment en mouvement.
Même quand elle est immobile au départ de
sa chute, la pomme se déplace toujours dans
le temps, elle avance vers le futur.
Lorsque la pomme ne subit aucune force la
courbure de l’espace-temps va progressivement
faire tourner sa trajectoire entre une vitesse
temporelle vers le futur et une vitesse spatiale
dirigée vers le sol.
La pomme se déplace en ligne droite mais
la courbure de l'espace-temps fait tourner
l’orientation de cette ligne droite entre
une direction temporelle et une direction
spatiale dirigée vers le bas.
On comprend que si la pomme tombe vers le
sol c'est parce qu'elle avait dès le départ
une vitesse temporelle dirigée vers le futur.
La courbure de l'espace-temps générée par
la terre n'a fait que convertir cette vitesse
temporelle en une vitesse spatiale.
Mais en tant qu’êtres humains nous ne percevons
pas la vitesse temporelle des objets.
Quand une pomme est lâchée dans l’espace
elle nous semble immobile, on ne perçoit
pas le fait qu’elle possède une vitesse
dans le temps.
De notre point de vue, nous n’avons accès
qu’à des tranches successives de l’espace-temps.
Nous voyons évoluer l’espace instant après
instant, et ce diagramme où les objets forment
des tubes au cours du temps, des lignes d’univers,
n’est pas forcément très intuitif.
Notre dernière étape va donc être de prendre
des tranches successives de ce diagramme,
de le découper instant par un instant, de
sorte à former une animation qui inclut le
caractère temporel.
La courbure de l'espace-temps qui fait plonger
les lignes droites dans la Terre devient un
mouvement de contraction de l'espace au cours
du temps.
Le rythme de cette contraction est constant
et perpétuel, car la courbure de l’espace-temps,
qui ne dépend que de la masse de la Terre,
ne varie pas au cours du temps.
Attention, il est très important de comprendre
que ce n’est pas la géométrie qui se contracte.
Ce sont les lignes droites qui se rapprochent
à cause de la courbure, et donnent l’impression
de se contracter.
Le phénomène est similaire à la surface
d'une sphère, la courbure y est constante,
mais les lignes droites semblent perpétuellement
se rapprocher.
C'est cette représentation qui me paraît
personnellement la plus appropriée pour visualiser
la relativité générale.
La Terre, car elle est très massive, déforme
l'espace-temps lui imprimant une courbure.
De notre point de vue, la courbure de l’espace-temps
apparaît comme une contraction perpétuelle
de l’espace au cours du temps.
En termes techniques on dit que le volume
renfermé par les géodésiques diminue au
cours du temps à cause de la courbure.
Cette grille d’espace qui se contracte représente
ce qu'on appelle les référentiels inertiels,
en chute libre.
A l’intérieur de cette grille, un objet
qui ne subit aucune force va conserver son
mouvement et sa vitesse.
Ainsi, si on lâche la pomme immobile, comme
elle ne subit aucune force, elle va rester
immobile par rapport à la grille, mais comme
la grille se contracte, la pomme va tomber
au cours du temps.
Avec cette façon de représenter la relativité
il est également facile de voir que le sol
de la planète accélère constamment vers
le haut, car il s’oppose de façon perpétuelle
au mouvement naturel de la grille.
Enfin, si on lance un objet sur le côté
avec une vitesse initiale, à chaque instant
l’objet ne subit aucune force, et va donc
continuer en ligne droite dans la grille.
Mais comme la grille se contracte, l’objet
est perpétuellement ramené vers le sol,
et c’est de cette façon que la Lune orbite
autour de la Terre, et que la Terre orbite
autour du Soleil.